pierre palmade de cette plage parce que
leur musique de jean michel jarre parole
de pierre palmade environ ça va ça va ça
s'est bien passé avant ouais bah ça va
très très très bien bien sûr ça va très
bien vous connaissez donc josé bové
laurie est à l'origine du buzz qui dany
boon jean michel alors vous le présente
plus et zabou qui croisait le film le
film de zabou marche très très bien se
souvenir des belles choses marche très
très bien très très bon démarrage
on est ravi parce que ça va quand même
une vingtaine d'années qu'elle se
prépare
j'ai beaucoup bossé 1 heureusement que
ça marche
émission mais il arrive du théâtre d'été
arrivent du terrain et pour ceux qui
pensent que l'émission est en direct
jamais il arrive du théâtre merci pour
l'enchaînement donc au théâtre ils se
sont aimés de dire il embrasse à sur la
bouche en belgique pensais pas je le
dirai non
j'élabore 7 michèle laroque donc la
pièce effectivement été écrite par
michel robin et pierre palmade et les
jouets par pierre palmade et la
merveilleuse michel larpe rouvreau gros
succès ouais ça ça va les gens viennent
ils allaient ils ont humé de la fin de
la première expérience c'est parfait en
chimie s'est pas enfermé avec quelques
mois c'est rare d'avoir un couple qui
marche et frédéric beigbeder disait dans
vsd que c'était en france le seul truc
était de qualité ipad
voilà donc ça c'est très sympa c'est
vrai et il a adoré ça non mais c'est
vrai voilà et puis après il ya un petit
peu de tourner non à la journée puis le
zénith alors c'est jouer ça au zénith
est un génie dans une configuration
humaine
on va faire avant la famille de
personnes très très près de la scène
ingénieuse parce que pas parce que les
les gens sont d'accord pour rennes